is the leonardo da step professor at cmu
and she's done a lot of like very
interesting work
but in the section of machine gearing
game theory security game
security games and eventual
sustainability
and uh she's also like a co-organizer of
the workshop
and today's will be talking to us about
reinforcement learning for complexity
games and beyond
so much fair and the floor is yours
thank you
and good afternoon everyone
it's a pity that i cannot be there in
person i hope that i can resume at least
national travels soon uh international
ones probably still aren't on vote uh
now starting from this week cmu is
allowing people to not wear masks on
campus so it seems like things are going
back to the normal uh mode
um yeah so
today i'm going to talk about our work
on learning for complex security games
and beyond
we are particularly interested in
challenges in security and environmental
sustainability and
whether the securities in the physical
world in the cyber world or in the case
of
like environmental sustainability where
the law enforcement agencies is trying
to fight against people who are doing
illegal logging either poaching or
overfishing we do see this defender
attacker type of interaction patent and
we want to see
how we can leverage ai to address those
problems
um
in the past
more than a decade there has been some
successful attempts to handling this
using machine learning and game theory
including my own work in the earlier
days uh we've worked on using
stackhover's security game model to
model the problem of protecting the
ferry lines like this is a stata island
ferry in new york
it's a straight line
for the ferry to move along and we the
coast guard people are worried about the
potential attacks that happened uh that
has happened in to other big boats in
the past where there is a small boat
packed with explosives and then run into
the run into the big boat so we modeled
this as a stackable game where the
defender is the leader and the
attacker's follower and our goal here is
to find out a strategy for the defender
which is a probability distribution over
multiple patrol routes so that we can
minimize the attacker's maximum expected
utility so here we can
write down the payoff matrix
with each row representing a possible
route for the defender each column
representing one possible attack
time and target for the attacker and
then try to figure out the solve this
game
through mathematical programming and
figure out the best probabilities for
each of the roots
and we did this and we made some
improvements by using flow based
representation
and
solve the linear program
to get the optimal defender strategy and
in the in lab experiments we showed that
it can indeed
reduce potential risk and this was
deployed in the field since 2013
and
here
the feedback we get from the coast guard
is that they feel that this
game theoretic solution indeed increased
the randomness and there has been some
reports saying that
our work together was the optimization
for protecting other parts of the port
uh is has led to 33 million dollar
saving in 10 years for the coast guard
to achieve the same security level and
it continues to impact the coast guard
patrol policy even now
so
that's the stack over security game
model success for protecting the fair
line and later on as we move to the
environmental sustainability domain we
started to
build new models the green security game
model for handling this type of problems
comparing to the
ferry protection domains in this case we
actually got a lot more data describing
the poaching activities happened in the
past
and in this case
we really want to not only reason about
the perfectly rational attacker but also
reason but probably more importantly
reason about the human behavior in this
case so we started to build machine
learning models to try to model the
bounded rationality of the cultures
we've tried various
versions of the machine learning methods
have an ensemble model and use the both
supervised learning and unsupervised
learning all together to get this
prediction of the heat map and it was
successfully led
to this field test in uganda and china
where the renters were sent to the
locations that are predicted to be
hotspots and they found
a large amount of poaching activities
which is even larger than what they
typically find
and actually as you can see here this is
me holding the snares we found in just
one day it's 22 snares in one day that's
a lot comparing to what they typically
find and also what we found is that
in the areas that are predicted to be
high poaching threat
areas
we got
we found many more snares comparing to
the areas that are predicted to be low
threat areas
so this
uh this all shows that the machine
learning model is able to
have a reasonable understanding of the
poetry's behavior
and building upon this behavior models
we still want to plan the patrols in
this case we again
try to formulate this problem
through mathematical programming and
here the variables are the patrol
efforts that we want to spend on
different areas
and we want to maximize some objectives
for example it could be just maximizing
the total amount of
snares being found so here we have the
machine learning model
and then we can use a piecewise linear
function approx to approximate uh what
the machine learning model tells us
and we can solve this mathematical
program and bring this to the
to solve this problem to get the patrol
routes and
later on when we try to bring these to
the
real world we also noticed that we may
also need to take into account the
terrain information not just like you go
from this location to this location
through a straight line but really to
figure out
how the terrain is like and generate
patrol routes that are compatible with
the turing by connecting those uh
terrain features like reach lines
streamlines all together and then design
the patrol routes on this so-called
virtual street map so this led to the
field test in malaysia where again
people found all kinds of animal
activity science and human activity size
so
now this whole
this whole thing the prediction of the
protein straps together with the
planning of the patrol route
has been
successfully integrated into a software
called smart which is a spatial
monitoring and reporting tool uh
supported by multiple global cultivation
agencies and used by more than 600
conservation sites worldwide and some
parks are already using it to predict
poaching spread and there hopefully will
be more field tests on the way
so we are excited about these successful
field tests and deployments of security
game models and green security game
models and these tests in turn reveal a
series of new research challenges and in
the past few years we have been
developing new ai techniques to tackle
these challenges for example how to
design patrol routes that are adaptive
to real-time information such as
footprints sound by the rangers
so for the i'm going to talk about these
challenges one by one so for the first
for the first challenge it is actually
motivated by a conversation with the
site managers they told us that they
don't necessarily always stick to the
pre-planned patrol routes because if
they found footprints
and they know that these footprints
don't belong to them they would try to
react to it sometimes
and i was asking them how do you how can
you tell that the footprints don't
belong to you as the the rangers and
then the site manager set managers told
us that in some sites the ranger team
can sometimes purchase a special type of
boots so that the footprint is very
distinctive so that if they observe the
footprints and it's not going to the
render team then they know this is from
the poachers
so if they found this then they would
decide whether they were they're going
to chase the purchase not
and here's there's some complications
here in the sense that if this is the
area that they have a lot of wrenches
and they know that the poachers are not
well equipped meaning there's no guns in
the poacher's hands then they will try
to chase them but in some other cases
they were worried about the poachers
having guns then if they see the the
footprints they say they may even avoid
the actual contact with the poachers by
taking a different pass
so anyway so they just there is a chance
that they would react to the real-time
information
so clearly the mathematical programming
based approach that we developed before
in the green security game it cannot
adapt to this more complicated case
so we instead model the problem as a
mock-up game in a great world we build a
new game model in this game model
uh the rangers starts from the patrol
post the starting point in this uh in
the middle of the grid here and the
poachers would move in this grid
and the
poachers can also place snares in some
of the snares as they see fit
and the rangers are also moving in this
grid and both branches and poachers can
leave footprints in the grid cells as
they walk
but they can
observe only the footprints in the cells
that they are in so
here we assume that they can
differentiate the footprint from
themselves and the footprints of others
and
besides each grid cell might have a
bunch of features like animal density
and other type of features
so our goal here is to find out what
would be a good strategy for the render
to use in the in this patrolling
we started with a simpler task we're
saying that okay assuming that the
poachers are following some heuristic
behavior model and we know that behavior
model ahead of time then in this case
this becomes a actually a reinforced
learning task
because from the ranger's perspective
poacher is just part of the environment
the render just needs to decide given my
current observation and my past
observation what which direction should
i go next
so we built the steep q uh learning
based uh method to compute the render
strategy against against the such a
poacher uh
here the imp uh we have this q network
which takes as input the observations of
footprints the animal density
distribution and a bunch of other
information that the
defender can the ranger can get and then
the output of this q network is going to
be just the q values for taking
different actions here we only have five
different actions going up down left to
right and standing still
and of course after extensive training
this q network hopefully can represent
uh like some promising scores uh and
tells us whether it is more beneficial
to go to each of these potential
directions
and that can help us help the rangers to
decide what action to take given
under any circumstances
so here's the result that we see the
training result indeed showed that we
can find a reasonable patrol strategy
for the render well the
strategy is that the render starts from
the patrol post and trying to go to the
perimeter of the area and then trying to
patrol along the perimeter until it sees
something like footprints or
other signs
however the strategy is highly
exploitable because the poachers uh
always the wrenches always start from
the patrol post and then go go to the
right and now go to the go down and
until it sees something so if the
poacher is smart enough then the poacher
might observe that there's
lack of randomness still in the patrol
strategy and can counter that
then how can we
handle this uh this
weakness uh
leveraging what we have learned in the
security games we know that it is
important to randomize so we want a
the policy for the defender and how can
we create such a randomized policy uh we
are treating a deterministic deepq
network policy for the ranger
as
just a single possible policy and we're
going to randomize over multiple uh dq
network represented policies
so
leveraging
the double oracle framework for solving
large-scale zero-sum games and also the
policy space response article framework
in multi-agent reinforcement learning we
treat a dq network as a single action
that can be taken by the players and our
goal now is to find a randomized policy
which is a probable probability
distribution over multiple deep queue
networks
to do so we will start with
two small sets of dpu networks for the
render and the poachers separately
each might contain only two or three
queue networks so here in this example
we start with three q networks for the
renderer and three for the approacher
and we call them gd and ga and we
compute the nash equilibrium using this
current set of dq networks
and then train a new dpr network that
best responds to the other players
current equilibrium strategy
and these new dpq networks will be added
to the set and then we can go back to
the computation step to
compute the equilibrium for this
enlarged game and we could continue
doing this until at some point uh we are
satisfied with the strategy we found and
then terminates
so this is a nice framework uh but a
challenge here is that uh it might take
too many iterations to get something
that is reasonable and even one
iteration requires the training of a dq
network which takes a lot of time
so we were thinking about how can we
improve this
the first idea that we had is to use
local modes for efficient training
we
we know that in the original problem the
poacher might get into the grid from
multiple locations like each of these
four corners of the grid can be the
entry points of the poachers now for the
local modes we're going to restrict the
poachers to enter the grid from a
specific entry point for example in this
local mode uh we restrict the portrait
to enter the grid from the upper left
corner and then in this local mode we
restrict the uh portrait to enter the
grid from the lower right corner and
then the training in these local modes
will be more efficient compared to the
original problem uh
and
we can train the agent in multiple local
modes in parallel
at the end of the local mode training
what we're going to get is a few dq
network represented policies
for uh the defenders uh for the renters
and for the purchase which are good in
the local modes
that's fine we are going to leverage
these
reasonable policies in the local mode as
and use them as a starting point for the
training in the original problem
so we're kind of treating them as a warm
start for the iterative process uh for
this uh double oracle framework
so in other words uh and in addition to
this local modes uh we also found that
we can use some domain specific
heuristic strategies to warm up the
process
so
uh if we put things together what we're
going to do is that
at the very beginning we're going to use
our domain knowledge to get some
heuristic strategies
that are we believe are reasonable to
start with and then we're going to send
these initial set of strategies to each
of these local modes where in each of
the local modes we're going to run this
double oracle type of framework but
restricting the portrait to enter the
grid cell a grid from one of the entry
points and we train for several
iterations and we get a bunch of
different uh render strategies and
cultural strategies for each of this
global mode and we call them these
strategies as gtk
and then we combine all the strategies
together uh
to to be this gt and then we start
continuing the training in the global
mode and then after a few more
iterations of training we output the
defender strategy uh at the end of it
so what we found is that with this um
training paradigm we can
have a way to get a defender strategy
that is more scalable than
counterfactual regret minimization and
also leads to a better solution quality
than the vanilla version of the
policy space resp response oracle the
vanilla version of double oracle applied
to the
markov game case
so that's what we uh learned from this
one uh
how can we deal with the real-time
information
uh the
the the second challenge that we uh
found from the real world is that we
need to do robust sequential p patrol
planning
um
why is that
so we analyzed the data from the queen
elizabeth national park in uganda and we
found that the patrol strategies used in
one time period would indeed have impact
on poachers behavior in the future
and also
the wildlife distribution might change
due to the past approaching activities
and that would impact the future
poaching this leads us to think that we
probably should not consider the patrol
planning as a one-shot planning problem
instead it is a sequential planning
problem because whatever patrol strategy
we choose now would have an impact in
the future
on the other hand
we also noticed that
in
using what our previous method we need
the poachers behavior model but
the data we have is still quite limited
that means our estimation of the
purchase behavior might not be very
accurate
um and also the purchase behavior model
might change over time
so how can we deal with such uncertainty
in this domain uh we need something that
is more robust so we turn from just
sequential planning to this robust
sequential planning
uh more formally we're dealing with a
problem where we have n targets
and we want to come up with a patrol
strategy that is a mapping from state to
actions where here the state it is
described as the previous actions
we have taken where action here is like
the patrol effort that we decided to
spend in the last time period and then
also the state includes the wildlife
density and the current time
the actions here is describing how much
patrol effort will be spent on each of
the targets
uh we assume that the poacher's behavior
model is known but there is an
uncertainty in the model so we here
consider a
uncertainty region saying that we have
these parameters in this uncertainty
region we don't know exactly is
the the values of these parameters
our goal is to learn a policy that can
minimizes the maximum regret
which is defined as we're trying to find
out a policy pi
such that
uh if we
uh such that we can maximize this regret
uh defined as
the difference between these two
quantities the first quantity is the
reward for the ranger
when
we know
the uh parameter the environment
parameter is z and we choose the policy
that is best against z so this pi star z
representing the optimal policy uh given
the environment parameter z
and the second quantity is the reward of
using my current policy or the actual
environment
parameter is z so that is like
if we choose my policy
uh pi and the environment parameter is
actually z then how much should i regret
comparing to the best
policy in hindsight
which is pi star z
and then
we consider the worst case among all
possible uncertain parameters and then
we choose the policy pi that can
minimize this worst case
performance worst case regret
if we look at this uh formula from a
different angle then this can also be
viewed as a zero-sum game between the
planner and the nature where the planner
is choosing the policy pi and the nature
is choosing the parameter
z and the alternative policy pi hat
where the best alternative policy pi hat
will be the pi star z
and again in such a zero-sum game any
deterministic choice can be easily
exploited and we again want to use a
randomized policy
so we use we propose this mirror
algorithm which is still having the
following this double article or the
policy space
response article framework but this time
we are going to solve a max regret game
so in every step we constructed this
game
between the planner and the nature where
the actions for the planner could be
just different policies and the
the actions for the nature could be the
parameter values plus the alternative
policy
and we compute the natural equilibrium
of this game and then try to learn the
best responses
against the other players equilibrium
strategy
uh and we added this newly learned best
responses
to
the game and we get a enlarged game and
come to solve the game again
after a few iterations we
we can terminate the process and i'll
put the
strategy for the planner which
is
going to be this robust
policy
so we compared this mirror
algorithm with several other uh possible
approaches for choosing the policy to
use and we can see that the regret of
using mirror is lowest
comparing to the other approaches so
here uh the maximum reward means that we
are going to choose a policy that
maximizes the worst
nature's choice
so this is like uh the most conservative
choice of of the policies well the
middle means that we're given the
parameter uncertainty region so we're
going to choose the middle value of in
that uncertainty region and treat that
as ground truth to pick our
patrol policy
and then random is that we're going to
randomly sample a value in the
uncertainty region and then plan against
that
so this is uh to show that
when we use this
mirror approach uh trying to find out a
robust strategy uh and make
patrol planning sequentially we can
indeed achieve this uh
strategy that is real that is
achieving a low regret overall
so that's the second challenge that we
face and how we handled it
the third one is the repeated
interaction when there is a unknown
attacker this is actually motivated
by the problem in a slightly related but
not exactly the security domains that we
just mentioned this is in the cyber
security domain because in cyber
security domain it is
very often that we face this diverse
group of attackers and these attackers
have varying sophistication and their
intent is unknown to the defender
and also in cyber security it is more
likely that the defender and attacker
may have repeated interaction that means
the defender can infer from the
attacker's previous actions and plan the
defense accordingly while on the other
hand the attacker knows exactly what
kind of type they are so the attacker
can plan the actions based on
their own
type but they also know that if they
take some action it might reveal
information to the defender so they may
need to take actions in a careful way to
maintain such informational advantage
and as a result this becomes a
sequential decision-making problem on
both sides comparing to the one-shot
security game model that we had
in the
earlier models
so
uh formally we could we consider such a
model where we have t round uh
game between the defender and attacker
and the in each round the defender can
allocate k resources to end targets
while in each round the attacker can
choose one target to attack
and attacker has a certain type the
reward for the attacker to successfully
attacking a target is actually
determined by his type
where the type is unknown to the
defender the defender only knows a prior
probability distribution over these
multiple types
and
the goal here for the defender uh for us
is to find something that is closer to
the perfect bayesian national
equilibrium because given the such
sequential interaction just the natural
equilibrium concept uh would
leads to
incredible threat so we we want to
enforce that the strategy we found is
still good from any decision point
onwards
and
actually there has been some work that
uses mathematical programming to solve
this problem
however
as we can expect
the mathematical programming based
approach cannot really solve large-scale
problems it can it can not even solve
problems with the number of target
the number of targets being larger or
equal than eight
so to tackle this problem in a more
scalable way we decided to use a
reinforced learning based approach we
proposed this temporary use the
self-play that is built upon four main
ideas the first is using a belief based
representation the second is used
backward induction and third is policy
learning and the last one is belief
space
approximation the we're going to go
through these ideas one by one the first
idea belief-based representation is
quite straightforward that is instead of
using a
a policy that is that maps the history
to actions we're going to use a policy
that directly maps a belief to actions
where here the belief is your current
belief of the probability distribution
over attacker types
and such a belief based representation
can help in the case with a long history
but the cost we need we need to pay is
that in the execution or test time we
need to always infer the posterior
belief after we observe the actions of
the other players
the second idea the backward induction
is
also
straightforward we are going to
have this reverse training process we
are going to train the strategy from the
last very last round all the way back to
the very first round
and
we for each of the round we will train a
value network and a policy network
sorry and we're going to leverage the
value network and policy network that
have already been trained in the future
round when we try try to train our
current round networks
and the benefit of doing this is that we
don't need to sample the entire
trajectory from round to zero all the
way to round uh l minus one but we only
need to sample one step trajectory from
uh round out to round l plus one
and in the actual implementation uh we
need to use a special reset function to
help achieve this
um
and this also means that for every
single round we're going to use a
separate network to represent the
defenders policy
um
in fact this can indeed uh leads to
improve the performance
the third idea the belief space
approximation
uh is that
well even if we're going to use
a different network for different rounds
we cannot handle this for many many
different beliefs
how can we do this we are going to
sample k belief vectors and then train
the strategies specifically conditioned
on this particular belief and the
particular round
and then if we want to
query what policy should we use for a
different belief we're going to use this
non-parametric approximation uh using
the distance metrics between
the
queried belief and the sampled belief
and then
to approximate the strategy that we can
use
and the last part uh the third part
uh the policy
learning part uh this is the
last part yeah the last part the policy
learning part we can actually use
different policy learning algorithms for
example we can use policy gradient uh in
the in this in this case we just need to
update the network parameters in each
training step um but comparing to the
standard uh policy grading steps we need
to
take into account the beliefs and we
need to adjust the update rule a little
bit
uh instead of using policy gradient we
can also use
regret matching to update our
policies where here
we need to use the regret
to
update the policies
and
by using this uh reinforced learning
based algorithm we can solve games that
are larger
comparing to the mathematical
programming uh based methods
and uh here as we can see uh the
mathematical programming based methods
can quickly run out of memory even when
we have uh more than eight targets or
arounds well we can handle those larger
cases
and more importantly our algorithm can
generalize to more general game settings
not restricted to this repeated security
game setting we can have this great
world games uh and we can use our
algorithm to solve it as well
um
so this is like the benefit that we get
by using the reinforcement algorithm but
of course comparing to the mathematical
programming based approach this
reinforced learning based methods
can find policies
that are
not
as good as the mathematical programming
ones
if the
game scale is small enough
hopefully by now i've illustrated a few
ways that we use spring force learning
for solving complex security games and
there are still there still exists
several general challenges uh for using
rl for security games
one is to have
those policies more interpretable and
explainable because in several security
domains it is important for the
stakeholders to really understand what's
going on and to be able to verify the
policy before they deploy the policy
and also using rl means that we need to
build the simulator or simulation
environment
and then train the policies in that
simulation environment and not and
inevitably there will be a gap between
the simulation and the real world and
how to deal with such gap is also a
general challenge that we face
um also
even in these security domains if we
want to launch anything in the field
then we will face those human attackers
how can we incorporate the human
behavior modeling into the rl framework
is also something that we uh
needs to keep thinking about and
improving upon
and
i have to admit that for all these
methods that we have introduced here
that uses rl for security games they are
not deployed yet because of all these
general challenges and we're still
trying to see how we can
over overcome those limitations and
bring these more flexible uh policies to
the real world
so
here we have this uh reinforced learning
for the security game like problems but
there are a lot more other problems
exist in the real world and
it involves multiple agents but it goes
beyond such defender attacker type of
interaction
i'm generally interested in leveraging
machine learning and game theory
and optimization to solve those problems
or at least to help tackle those
problems as well so in the rest of the
talk i'm going to mention one specific
problem and i'm trying to invite people
to discuss or brainstorm what we can
potentially do there
this is the food rescue domain
we
reducing
we know that
uh
reducing food waste and ensuring food
securities is something that we always
want to achieve then how can we leverage
ai to help that
that's something that we want to tackle
here in pittsburgh we have a platform
called 412 food rescue it rescues good
food by connecting restaurants grocery
stores or cafes that have perfectly good
but not sealable food with local
communities in need of food for example
single mom shelters and the platform
rely on the volunteers to deliver the
food
so they have the smartphone app it posts
the food rescue requests on the app and
the volunteers can then claim a rescue
on the app and pick up the food from the
donor and deliver it to the recipient
organization some of these photos shown
here are actually taken when i myself
worked as a volunteer
and delivered the food from cmu cafe to
a local community
in this problem clearly there's no
defender attacker type of thing but we
still have a lot of decision makers
involved the donors recipients the
volunteers and the platform
we in the past decided to work on the
specific interaction between the
volunteer and the platform because one
pain point of the platform is that they
are uncertain which kind of rescues will
be claimed
and
to help improve the claim rate of the
rescues they use this notification
scheme notification and intervention
scheme once there is a rescue published
on the smartphone app they will send
notifications to all the volunteers that
leaves in five miles of the pickup
location
and then they will wait for 15 minutes
if they don't have any volunteers to
claim that rescue they would then notify
all the volunteers on the platform
60 minutes before the deadline of the
pickup if there's still no no one claims
it they would have this human dispatcher
jump in and try to call the volunteers
or text to the volunteers that they are
familiar with and just back them to help
with that rescue request
but of course they don't have enough
human dispatchers to handle these uh
requests one by one and also they don't
really want to spend uh send too many
notifications to the volunteers because
that might make the volunteers get bored
and even lose interest to help with any
of these rescue requests in the future
so what we were doing here is that we're
trying to see how we can uh provide
better intervention and notification
schemes to avoid excessive notification
and also reduce the human dispatcher's
workload
well the first idea we had is okay we
are still following what they're doing
now but we're going to change these
parameters in their current scheme
we're trying to find out the best values
of x and y and z so that we can achieve
something that is better and more
specifically we formulate we formulate
this as an optimization problem with the
goal of minimizing the expected number
of volunteer notifications and the
expected number of human interventions
with this lambda parameter controlling
the weight of these two and we want to
make sure that the claim rate
is no
less than their current claim rate so we
want to change the intervention scheme
but we don't want to do harm to the the
key uh indicator that they care about
the claim rate so we solved this problem
using branch and bound and leveraging
the data that we have in the past
so by optimizing the scheme using data
from may 2018 to december 2018 and
testing on the data from january 2019 to
may 2019 we found out two new
intervention schemes that can bring
benefit to them
we show them for example this
first one the first intervention scheme
that if you send notifications to people
within 5.5 miles of the pickup location
and wait for 16.5 minutes
and to send out the second wave and
having the human dispatcher jump in only
45 minutes before the deadline of the
pickup time then you can
reduce the human intervention by thirty
thirteen percent without really uh
increase your notifications
and they were happy with this potential
improvement and they decided to deploy
this intervention scheme
since february 2020
and we collected and analyzed the data
before and after the deployment of this
new scheme and as we all know the
breakout the outbreak of the covet
impacts people around the world starting
from early night 2020 and in pearsberg
the life here is impacted significantly
since the beginning of march so we
separated the data before march and that
after march
and as we can see here
uh the first row is before is the old
scheme where the second and third row is
like the new scheme and
what we observe is that after the new
scheme is deployed the claim rate goes
up the average time needed from
publishing a rescue request to having a
volunteer claim it goes down and the
average number of notifications sent is
lower
this trend continues even after the
covet impacted the area
these preliminary results they are
promising but also we know that there
might exist many confounding factors
and to get a more confirmative claim we
would need controlled experiments
but at the same time we feel like well
we can do better than just changing the
parameter values so we propose this
rescue specific notification scheme to
further improve the notification
efficiency we want to send the first
wave notifications to volunteer that are
more likely to claim the rescue
the idea we have is to treat the problem
as a recommended system we want to
recommend volunteers to each new rescue
request so we train a neural network
based model that can predict whether a
rescue will be claimed by a volunteer
given the features of the rescue and the
features of the
volunteer
when a new rescue request comes in we
apply this training model to all the
volunteers with this rescue and send
push notifications to the top k
volunteers
this idea sounds promising and we indeed
find out it can improve the
hit rate meaning the not the the chances
that
the first wave volunteers can claim the
rescue however the caveat is that we
found this learning model discover some
very active volunteers and keep sending
them notifications almost all the time
as we can see here this small portion of
the volunteers receives more than 1000
notifications in the test time
so this is definitely not good and to
resolve this problem we decided to
combine machine learning and online
planning rather than greedily taking the
top k volunteers we enforce some
constraints such that each volunteers
receives at most l notifications every
day and when a new rescue comes we will
project a set of future rescues based on
historical data and then solve a mixed
individual linear program subjected to
the notification limit constraint to
determine who to send the the
notifications to
uh and this resolves the over
concentration issue and achieves a uh
hit ratio at top k of 0.65 which is
still his significantly higher than the
current practice so here let me explain
what is this hit ratio at top k that
means we send the first wave
notifications to
around 664
volunteers and then we check
what is the likelihood that we have
one of the volunteers who got the
notification claimed the rescue just
before the first batch of notifications
so that we don't need to send another
wave of notification to other volunteers
so that's the hit ratio at top k
and uh in fact now we are working with
412 foot rescue and trying to launch a
controlled field test starting in weeks
so that we can have a more systematic
comparison with
what we have done before and with this
new
notification scheme
and at the same time we also think about
like the longer term effect of this
well
as we can see here what we're doing is
that we learn from historical data we
optimize the intervention or
notification scheme and then we want to
deploy this new notification scheme and
during the deployment we actually can
collect more data which we can use to
further improve the learn model and
improve the optimization
and however if we look at this learn
optimize deploy and learn scheme
there are a bunch of challenges in
general for example we don't really have
a huge amount of data to start with and
also we know that the intervention we
use in this case the notification scheme
we use would affect the data
distribution and also even the domain
experts may not perfectly know what kind
of objective they want to optimize
and
how can we make this entire
alternative process work better we tried
to think of ways to handle this we have
some initial ideas here we propose this
banded data driven optimization with a
no regret algorithm to
determine which
notification scheme to use in each in
each uh step
uh here this is still an initial attempt
to try to analyze this problem we
there's no no
short term plan to deploy this in the
field yet but uh also i think this is
something that not only applies to food
rescue but applies to many other many
many other problems as well we have this
learn optimize deploy and learn
iterative process and how can we deal
with a bunch of challenges in this
process
um as i mentioned uh
we we had this some initial attempts to
tackle this problem but we do see a lot
more open problems in this space
previously we worked on rust sharing
platform as well and in those problems
we're saying okay we know the drivers
are strategic they will try to game the
system no matter what pricing or
dispatching a scheme you're going to use
the platform is going to use
and that's because the drivers want to
make more money
and in this case we rely on the
volunteers then do volunteers still try
to game the system especially once they
know when they know that we are
determining the notification scheme
based on their past behavior
uh and also we want to see how can we
better incentivize the volunteers
without any payment because this is
completely non-profit how can we
understand their incentives and then
better incentivize them
and the last thing as we mentioned like
because of the sequential planning
nature because of this
learn
optimize deploy and learn process how
can we come up with better ways to
handle those practical challenges in the
sequential planning these are all
problems that i think
worth
discussing and i hope that will be
people who are interested in these
problems and would like to discuss with
us
so that's it for what i would like to go
over and i'm happy to take questions and
just discuss with you guys
thank you very much ferry
opening the floor two questions
hi
um i have one question in particular uh
would you watch the stackable games
models uh sec your your security
problems i guess
in all of these settings you assume uh
that you can model basically a problem
just using uh
just by figuring out the right uh payoff
functions for both defender and just
attacker i was wondering if you ever
considered actually also putting
restrictions onto the action set of
uh the defenders in your settings so
that maybe sorry of the attackers in
your settings so that um
maybe like the leader in the stackelberg
game could take action such as to
restrict the actions
uh the followers could take
yeah that's very good point uh so it's
like the defender not only
can deploy the security resources but
can potentially impact the game
structure in some sense right exactly
yeah yeah so we actually had a paper on
this we were in that paper we're talking
about the defender having the capability
of manipulating the payoff structure
directly
so for example this is
actually true in some of the problems
like in wildlife innovation for example
we do see the
agencies would change the fine the
amount of the fine if the poacher get
caught so think about this it's kind of
like the defender is actually changing
the
payoff of the attackers as a way to
try to reduce the attacker's utility
reduce the poaching activities and then
and also worldwide fund for nature or
other conservation agencies they would
run campaigns trying to
advertise that rhino rhino horns
comes from as
comes from the same material as the
nails so there's no special effect of
rhino horns and trying to reduce the
demand for rhino horns and effectively
that can reduce the
attacker's reward even if they succeed
in poaching the rhinos so
like of course all these changes in the
payoffs would pay would lead to a cost
and the defender can choose to pay some
cost to change the game structure and
then to allocate their defensive
resources to uh patrol and
to reduce the actual coaching activities
so we do some work there and we found
that indeed even with some small budget
on changing the game structure the
defender can win an advantage in this uh
combat against the attackers and we
haven't thought specifically about
restricting the action set but i think
that's also worth considering
okay gotcha thank you very much
hi
i'm i'm curious about
the the problem you raised of making
your reinforcement learning strategies
more interpretable or explainable
i'm curious if you think the the way
forward is to explain the the
complicated inner workings of these dqns
and all of these policies that you learn
or if it's to train simpler strategies
that are easier to explain in the first
place
yeah so that's very good yeah that's
very good question and recently we were
we worked on a survey paper on
interpretable reinforced learning and we
found that people are trying hard on all
these different directions some people
are trying to say oh let's just have
this uh
policies that are easier to understand
like decision tree based policies and
then some other people say that okay i'm
going to just to come up with natural
language based explanations uh for those
very complicated neural network policies
uh i think there are people who are
doing both from my perspective i would
uh slightly lean towards focus on
generating simpler policies first and we
have some ongoing work trying to coming
up with
uh more
simpler like decision tree based
policies for multi-agent reinforcement
learning um so that's
what we think is uh a starting point uh
but of course i think there's a lot more
to do it depends on the actual needs of
the domain experts
based on our interaction with the
experts at least for the wildlife
conservation domain
they it's easier to explain a decimal
tree to them in fact when we started
building the behavior models of the
poachers to make predictions of protein
activities uh we we started with the
decision tree policies with a very
shallow design tree and explained to
them that okay the students tree says if
the distance to the village is small and
the animal animal density is high then
we predict there's a high protein risk
so in this way like the the way experts
can understand there and there's a trust
built between them and the ai and then
it makes them to be like more
open-minded to other more complicated
models
so in your work on the uh rl for
security games uh was
was all the learning done offline um say
with data that you collected before did
you consider trying to use
data that you saw online to update your
policy
um uh in kind of an adaptive manner
yeah that's very good point so the the
work that i introduced here in this talk
are all based on the case where we build
a simulator uh and part some of the
parameters in the simulator is built
upon historical data but
uh we're going to train the rl agent in
this simulation in the simulator and to
get the policy and then deploy the
policy and how to combine this
historical data and the
actual data that we're going to get
after we deployed it is something that
we also considered we have several
vendor learning based work uh to handle
this uh we're trying to say that can we
um
can we just treat this as as abandoned
learning problem uh where we try to have
some initial strategy built upon
historical data but every time as we
collect the more data we change
our strategy uh
slightly and then to deploy and to
collect more data so that's something
that we have considered a little bit
it's just slightly different framework
we consider bandit learning instead of
reinforced learning uh i think
that one uh also makes sense uh to me as
a way to better
make better use of both historical data
and the online data per se
any other questions
all right i just have a quick follow-up
question to the
reinforcement learning approach and
explainability like do you do you
actually want the policy to be
explainable doesn't that make it easier
for the attacker to figure out
like you want it to be explainable for
the defender but not for the attacker
isn't there some sort of tension
between these or
they're equally like an explainable
policy can be just as good as one that
is not explainable
i see yeah that's a good point yeah we
haven't thought about that part yet i
think uh
in the current formulation several of
the game models that we're considering
is actually zero sum so
uh
there's less concern uh in if it is zero
sum game because uh we can
try to make uh
by increasing the defender's utility in
the zero sum game we're trying to say
that even if the attacker knows what the
defender is doing
they they can only achieve this much
but in practice i can see that the human
human attackers understanding of the
defender strategy might be imperfect and
how can we incorporate that such
misunderstanding or the gap in the
attacker's understanding of the defender
strategy and the actual defining
strategy could be
uh something that was
taking into account when we design the
strategies for the defender
okay
that's it in terms of questions uh let's
thank faye once again thank you thank
you all
georges you're going to have a break
right